in the fourth and five we're just  getting the word in our headphones from  our producer Spencer Julian about some  very sobering news the NBA has decided  to suspend gameplay following the  conclusion of tonight's games now during  the hiatus of the suspension they'll  figure out trying to determine what the  next steps will be but the word that  just came out just moments ago is the  NBA is going to temporarily suspend the  season from now who knows what's going  to happen going forward they're  reportedly Rigobert has tested positive  for the corona virus that was obviously  one of the reasons why that Utah  Oklahoma City game was suspended